you would have thought raising interest  rates by six point five percent might  have been at the kind of strong signal  that would reassure the markets yeah  that's got to be a scary moment when you  do something that big and dramatic and  it doesn't stick the only two weeks ago  that President Putin has said you know  rush is prepared for cataclysmic  scenarios but watching what's happening  with the ruble between oil prices and  this new sanctions bill that passed both  houses that it looks like brushes not  prepared for cataclysmic scenarios one  of the ways that they could do something  maybe to stop this implosion if you like  is to change their stance for instance  on issues like Ukraine to stop buzzing  airplanes you know in the Baltic mr.  Putin is still well over eighty percent  approval so he's in a position where  maintaining sanctions and find having  scapegoats is actually not only useful  for but it may be seen as critical in  this very dangerous period